I work in the economic and financial  affairs Directorate and more  specifically the insurance and  securities unit so involves doing lots  of research to draft background  information that's for my colleagues for  committee chairs and for member state  delegations it involves daily contact  with colleagues you know whether that's  preparatory meetings attending working  party groups I've really enjoyed working  here at the council and firstly you get  to meet lots of people from all the  other member states you get to work on  really closely on issues that affect  European citizens as well and with that  learning how the EU policymaking process  works and especially how member states  negotiate with one another on  legislation and actually how the  institutions themselves so the  Commission the Parliament and the  council negotiate and interact with one  another  the successful legislation  you